las inundaciones en el occidente de
alemania se están convirtiendo en un
desafío cada vez mayor para los
servicios de emergencia en lo que ya
está siendo descrito aquí en alemania
como una crisis las autoridades del
estado federado de renania palatinado
uno de los más afectados explicaron que
en ese estado se trata de un desastre
sin precedentes mientras tanto la
canciller alemana angela merkel quien
está de visita oficial en washington
explicó que está conmocionada por lo que
escribió como una catástrofe agregando
sus condolencias para las familias de
las víctimas y su agradecimiento para
quienes están trabajando en las labores
de rescate mientras tanto el ministerio
de defensa alemana explicó que está
aumentando su ayuda y que ha enviado
cientos de soldados a las zonas más
afectadas para ayudar con las labores de
emergencia